[inaudible].
So what are some of the policies of the new,
if the new right becomes,
takes over the conservative movement or,
right.
So whatever that is,
that whether they burn the thing down or where they,
whether they infiltrated or whatever,
the,
the people that care about these ideas broadly that you're talking about,
what does it actually look like politically?
Like what are the things that they would be fighting for?
Polisci this is what's hilarious is you have a group who's United only by their
oppositions.
Progressivism.
What do you want to do?
They have no even close to unanimity.
Someone UN,
military,
John Down like just martial law.
Some like me,
not for me.
Not For me.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right,
good.
Uh,
someone,
a complete liberty meaning anarchy,
uh,
somewhat,
um,
a restriction of the right to vote.
Uh,
some want to accelerate,
they want more leftism cause they think if you accelerate and amplify,
the system is going to collapse because cause the inherent contradictions and
leftism so you have no consensus whatsoever about what the next steps.
And same thing with like for example,
they think people think,
oh,
everyone in this group likes Trump.
Some of them love Trump completely.
And,
and uh,
unabashedly and culture who I've talked about in this book,
she's come out very hard against him and I think she called him a moron or
something like that.
What do you make of her related to Trump?
It was like she was huge pro Trump,
but then he's not know he's not building the wall fast enough for her or a
couple of the other things.
It's like subculture.
You still also some real politic involved culture used to be a real trial,
right?
She knew how to say the exact right things to upset people.
Now she's gotten much more serious,
uh,
and ideological in her later books.
Uh,
it's interesting to see her relationship with Trump.
I mean she said at one point she thought America was like 90%,
no chance.
Now it's maybe 40% because of Trump's election.
Uh,
she's very 90% of trans.
What that American's done,
we're done.
She thought it was like,
we're over 90% chance.
And then she was like,
okay,
maybe it's 40% that were done because Trump got all that there.
Um,
I can't really speak for her,
but she is a very kind of a interesting character.
And I discuss your ideas at length cause her book Adios America was probably the
most influential book of the 2016 Election Cycle.
That's the book where Trump got the idea of they're sending the rapists.
Uh,
who do you find you can debate with on the other side of this?
So I get you can,
you can be around people on the right that you disagree on a lot of these
different things and you don't come out of the racist camp and all that stuff.
Do you find that there are some good actors on the left that you can engage
with?
Oh,
I have a lot.
Uh,
people like Glenn Greenwald,
Michael Tracy,
Jimmy door.
Um,
I actually don't debate cause I'm not interested in persuasion.
I'm just there to have fun.
And I think debating is often a waste of time and it's always a waste of time.
I mean,
the cost benefits.
So I don't really do,
I've had a few people on my show who are,
you know,
pretty far left.
No Mickey constant was on.
Uh,
I also you'd like to baiting with conservatives.
Um,
cause I really disagree with them and since I'm coming at them from this center
line on that,
uh,
conservatism,
conservatism is progressivism driving the speed limit.
So,
uh,
one of the things I discuss in this book is National Review.
My favorite Paleontology magazine in the late nineties,
they had this,
uh,
editorial comparing the fight for gay rights to a theoretical fife for
necrophilia and saying,
what's the difference between fighting for two men to have sex with each other
as opposed to,
uh,
having sex with a corpse?
And it was just a very disturbing article,
but now the conservative case for gay marriage.
So what are principles are there that would have you say that then and have you
say this now.
So it's disturbing then.
And the a hypocrisy is disturbing,
uh,
to this day as well.
So you're,
you're more,
you care more about the hypocrisy of it,
not the,
you don't care about gay marriage.
Well,
I,
I mean I care about both.
I mean,
if you're going to have a principal,
I would have more respect for someone to be like,
gay marriage is wrong because of the Bible,
blah,
and stick to that as opposed to I'm anti gay then cause I'm the phony and now
Mancy gay now cause I'm a phony.
You're bringing nothing to the table.
Yeah.
But I mean you protect you specifically.
You don't care.
I do.
I wouldn't want,
I don't care.
I'm glad that you're married to that too.
Well,
that's what I meant.
I mean,
you don't care.
Karen and negative sense.
Oh,
of course.
No,
no.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Please Mary.
Whatever you want.
Yeah.
Mary a corpse.
We'll know.
Well yeah,
but you do have limits only if they're good to like,
oh,
only if they're good then you can marry a quarter.
Yeah.
Um,
how crazy do you think things are going to get as we roll into 2020?
Because I think we're still
possible healthfully.
And here's something that I,
I've called that once I say no one can really kind of deny it.
A historically the president or the nominee hasn't really engaged with the other
party's primary process.
For the first time in history,
a sitting president is going to be live tweeting the debates and the primary of
the other team.
And not only that,
it's not like he's going to combinate like,
oh,
I disagree with his economic plan.
He's loving nukes in his Trump Ian style.
And none of these 23 candidates are good to know what to do.
And none of their advisers who are getting paid a lot of money,
social media experts,
I'm going to have know what to do.
There's no blueprint.
And the question becomes,
is it a badge of honor that Trump is clowning me?
Does that make me a strong candidate?
Do I ignore him?
Am I above the fray?
Like historical people used to do like,
oh my opponent,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
So this is going to be absolutely hilarious.
And you want that hilarity.
The more chaos,
the better politically.
Yeah.
I don't want people to be able to get together and impose their will.
So what if you were one of the 23,
what would you do
as someone that knows how to play the trolling game that knows how to,
you know,
throw the bombs back,
let's say,
what would you do?
Trump.
So you're onstage trumps,
you know,
do it as Twitter thing.
You get off stage,
you see what's going on,
what would you do or what would you tell if you were an advisor to one of these
people,
what would you do?
Oh,
well I,
I know you don't want to give away all your texts have designed,
I would never advise it,
but in all seriousness,
uh,
what I would do is if you look at when he was a comedy central roast and they
ask them beforehand,
they said,
what jokes can you make and can you make?
The only thing he wasn't comfortable being joked about was that he's not as rich
as he wants as he claims he is.
So since that's his line,
I would hit him with that line as much as possible.
But at the same time,
it's hard to troll someone who is that?
You know,
Hiroshima in a China shop.
I mean,
he's easy.
It is,
but I don't,
Justin Amash got him pretty good I think over the weekend with coming out in
favor of impeachment.
I think that really ruffled his feathers were on the,
oh no.
You know what it is.
This is what I would hit him with.
I would say you brag during the campaign that you would hire the best and
smartest people.
How come all these people are resigning,
you know,
and,
and hit him with that.
His big core competency,
alleged core competency.
How competent do you think he is or it isn't a,
I actually forgetting the tactic,
the trolling tactic and Twitter as competent as being president,
but as being protein.
It's hard to tell because there's,
I've that theory that probably isn't that crazy that when you become president,
they sit you down and they're like,
all right,
this is what you can do and this is what you can't do.
The fact that Obama was droning everyone all the time.
It seems like it's out of his,
you know,
peacenik background or it could be that,
he was a closet,
you know,
Hawk the whole time.
We don't know.
I don't think any of us really know what it's like to be president.
The fact that he hasn't gotten a lot of his big promises through is kind of a
big deal.
The fact that he has taken on unprecedented opposition and his head is still
being held hide.
His approval ratings are still relatively high.
I mean that's a bit of an accomplishment.
So since you wrote a book on North Korea.
Yeah.
And there's been a little,
I think last time I had you on,
maybe they were in the beginnings of some of those discussions.
Where are we at with North Korea right now?
I am.
So North Korea has this secret weapon which causes everyone on earth to have
amnesia.
And what happens is North Korea goes through these cycles as night follows day,
which is there'll be warmongers,
we're going to nuke America,
we're going to kill everyone,
blah,
blah.
And then six months later we want peace.
Please work with us,
please work with us.
And they've just gone back to the war cycle and everyone's like,
oh my God,
we've never heard this for North Korea had sentence president Trump to death.
They were threatening to new Guam and Alaska and even previously that they were
threatened in new Boston.
So it's,
this is how they this terrible,
oh,
come on now.
Um,
so this is where they are right now.
I am very hopeful.
The thing I'm very happy with with president Trump is that North Korea is now on
the front pages because we need to engage with this most evil country.
And I was on Fox and friends first or a while ago and they said,
what is your big concern with the summit?
And I said to continuing enslavement of the North Korean people so that whenever
you're looking at this issue,
always ask,
in my view,
what does this mean for these 20 million hostages who are being kept enslaved by
this evil government that starved it's population on purpose during the 90s and
killed one to 2 million people.
That's not funny.
So do you think that Trump is sort of the perfect person for this,
that as North Korea vacillates back and forth with all this rhetoric that Trump
actually match them
at that and that might be the thing that kind of allows a detente
I don't know about perfect,
but I you have to have hope for these people especially,
I mean not to sound whatever.
Once you've been there and you've seen people there,
everyone I met in North Korea is still there.
Like every single person I saw on the street,
every kid,
every grandma.
And it messes with your head because this is what 2012 they come into.
Your life has changed since 22 I'll think of much mine has and none of theirs
has.
I still see my guide,
you know,
pictures of her on Instagram and she's still trapped and she's like a
millionaire there,
but she's still trapped in that prison with those Gildan bars.
So it's very disturbing.
How does an anarchist care about foreign policy?
Well,
because this the go since the governments,
the enemy,
this is the most evil government on earth.
This is a pretty,
uh,
easy syllogism.
Interesting.
You don't really think about that though.
I mean generally when people think of a more libertarian view of the world,
it's like,
no,
just let everybody do whatever the hell.
Well,
I'm not going to let the government do whatever the hell they wanted these
people.
Yeah,
I mean,
and that's the other thing,
like we have it.
So even though it's not your government,
these are human beings and you know,
being born in the Soviet Union,
being Jewish,
these were two chances.
My family could have been sent to a concentration camp.
So the fact that we have concentration camps right now,
that you could see them on Google earth,
you know what,
not high school,
I was talk about how the Holocaust happened.
How the hell happened?
Something similar happened in the 90s in North Korea against its own population.
So this is something that maybe other people don't care.
But for me,
it's kind of like there,
but for the grace of God go I and when I met the guy that I had,
she had the same haircut my mom had in like 1982 which is a cutting edge in
North Korea,
but it's just looking at like a sliding doors thing and it's like,
holy crap,
I could have been born here and instead of sitting here in my Willy Wonka
costume,
you know,
who knows what would've happened to me.
What do you think's going to happen to the traditional conservatives?
Oh God,
I,
I is it absolutely over because they can't withstand what's coming on both sides
of it.
I don't see how they come back because I don't,
they didn't bring that much to the table to begin with as opposed to like give
it socking to the left and now Trump is talking to the left more than anyone
else has.
I'm going to be talking to Ben domination,
you know,
not that long from the federalists.
And I'm very curious to hear his take on this book and this thesis because it
could be because he's someone that is more of a traditional,
hardcore,
pure,
conservative,
mutual respect.
I like him a lot.
Um,
but I don't see how they regain,
uh,
this party especially because if one of the big issues with conservatism and
maybe republicanism is young people,
young people are going to be drawn to humor and edginess and memes and they're
not going to be drawn to kind of like a,
Hey,
remember Reagan?
Reagan's great,
he ended the Cold War.
But this is not going to be a selling point for your movement.
And also the,
I think young people are also drawn to aggression,
um,
and kind of flipping over tables.
And that's what the new right does offer them.
Are there political leaders outside of however much
Trump is involved in this?
Are there some other people that you like?
I know that's the weird thing.
It's like you don't want a political leader per se,
because you don't want to be personally who I like.
Yeah.
Well or that you think can sort of grab some of these pieces and do something
good in your estimation?
Uh,
I can't,
I'm sure there are Tulsi Gabbard.
I like anyone who brings more of the antiwar message.
Uh,
funny you wrote a book called the New Right,
and you're picking a candidate who running as a democrat.
Sure.
Anti War Democrat,
but I,
interesting.
I would love it if there was a complete consensus in Washington that war is a
last resort and an absolute nightmare.
That is my goal.
So I just like,
we agree that slavery is a nonstarter.
The like,
sure,
I'll get the argument that maybe we have to go to war,
but the fact that we can be so glib about it and be like,
oh yeah,
we're just gonna add.
Here's another example.
Do you think that we've crossed a little bit of a threshold when it comes to
war?
I mean,
I feel like the mistakes of Iraq and nobody knows why the hell we're in
Afghanistan still Trump is not beating wardrobes.
You know,
there's,
there's stuff about,
there's always this over the top rhetoric related to Iran,
but I see,
I don't sense,
this is a guy that wants to just,
I think he's actually very against the blog.
These nation building,
the blood lust of the establishment,
which I include.
The corporate press cannot be overstated.
Uh,
when 2016 Trump's the nominee,
we heard it every single day.
He's crazy.
He's going to give us to world war three.
He's going to get pissed off at a tweet from China and press the nuclear button.
Remember we heard this all the time.
Carly fury and I got asked this the second debate,
the first question,
do you trust president Trump with his finger on the nuclear button?
And now China has hacked our systems.
Russia has tried to interfere with our elections,
and the press is constantly saying,
do something about it.
Do something about,
do something.
I'd do something about Venezuela.
So the fact that he's not getting us into world war three is not being used as a
slight against him by the same people who regarded that as a problem when he was
a nominee.
It's horrific.
And this has been a longtime coming.
How much since,
uh,
the,
we talked about yellow journalism in high school.
I remember the Spanish American war,
and then they pretend they went away.
It didn't go away.
The same press wants,
if it bleeds,
it leads.
They can't wait to get us into another engagement.
It's,
it's disgraceful what happened.
What has to happen with the press then?
And I mean this in terms of cable news,
mainstream news,
Network News,
I mean this vox Huffpo sure.
The battle is speed.
All the battle is won when the average corporate journalist is regarded with the
exact same way as the average tobacco executive.
They have a job.
Uh,
they're promoting their product.
Their product is cancerous and deadly.
They're often bright people.
They're often good people,
but be aware of what it is that they're selling you.
So how do we find some people to trust in the mix of all of this,
in this big mess?
Uh,
trust,
but verify.
I mean,
I'll use the Reagan.
trust is,
I'm not interested in trusting people initially in,
in,
in a trusting ideas and creating mechanisms that people can't enforce their
wills.
The trust won't be necessary.
Like I don't need to trust like Ebay,
right.
I don't need to trust that other guy is going to be a honorable because there
are different systems I can get my money refunded,
so and so forth.
So there's no reason for me to have a political leader trust because
systemically he's going to betray me at some point or another.
God,
there's a lot here at malice.
Thank you.
Take me somewhere else altogether.
W what do you mean?
Where else do you want to go in this conversation right now?
Oh,
well I got,
I mean,
I've got a million things rattling here.
We're here.
We're your humerus.
Yeah.
Doesn't it bother you?
I,
one of the things I defend in this book is dark humor.
And here's the let's tie back to North Korea.
Yeah.
I knew a refugee and he said,
so when people say that's not funny,
right?
Uh,
it's this puritanism HL Mencken said,
puritanism is the idea that someone somewhere is happy,
right?
I knew this refugee North Korean refugee,
and he went to high school here and he's talking to his friends and they go,
hey,
remember when we were kids we had Pokemon?
And he goes,
yeah,
except instead of Pokemon and watch my dad's starved to death.
Now are you going to tell him that's not appropriate?
Right,
right.
Are you,
uh,
do you know what it's like to,
what is his coping mechanisms?
I use it.
Do you know what it's like to watch someone's hungry,
starve to death?
And it's your own dad?
We can never wrap our heads around this.
So for you to tell him that kind of joke is not appropriate.
How dare you buying McFarland?
A great comedian was roasting Jim Norton and she said,
your show is so unlistened bubble.
I'd rather hear my daughter drown.
Now that's very dark,
but are you telling me she doesn't love her daughter?
Are you telling me she doesn't know how to tell a joke?
So the metaphor I use when people say a certain subject is not,
uh,
appropriate for humor.
I say it's like flour.
Flou F L O U R is flower food.
Well,
no one eats flour,
but everyone eats it when it's processed and baked.
Right?
So same thing with jokes.
This darker the subject,
the harder it is to make it palatable.
And I have examples of,
you know,
they made me cut one joke,
but I have examples of all sorts of,
you know,
subjects that are supposed to be off limits.
And maybe you personally don't find it funny if someone's been assaulted and
they're like,
you know,
these kinds of jokes set me off.
That's there.
But the idea that no one,
yeah,
she'd find that funny,
isn't it?
Well,
it's also stealing something that's very human is that we use humor.
It comedy is tragedy plus time.
We use humor to be able to look back on the past.
I mean if Mel Brooks couldn't of made fun of Hitler,
couldn't of made fun of the Holocaust,
that was,
that was actually healing for,
I'm sure for him personally,
but for millions of other people.
But the establishment which gets by on legitimacy and quality conversation,
it cannot abide that court jester laughing at them
is do you think that's why they took out the AOC parody on on Twitter because it
was really freaking out.
They took out a lot of parody accounts and it's strange.
All those Trump parody accounts are still up and the Para and sign live,
which is their right and their great do it make for you should be making on the
president.
But you're not saying that life is great,
but why not?
Sure.
Pretty crappy.
I haven't watched it in one.
Yeah,
no,
I mean I haven't watched it in 15 years,
but every time I see a ten second clip it's like,
it's basically as basically as good as the gene wilder Willy Wonka movie.
So that's a call back,
my friend.
Yeah,
I understood it was a call back.
It's just the ludicrous thing I've
ever heard in my entire life.
Someone who I love your outside the box thinking and yet
it's bizarre.
The point is,
uh,
humor is,
if it's this,
it's a Jewish thing.
It's this Jewish thing of laughing to keep from crying and it's a very waspy
thing,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
you know,
you don't make the kind of jokes,
the dinner table.
And just because something isn't for someone doesn't mean it's not for no one.
And one of the elements of the evangelical left is the idea of universalism.
Everything has to be inclusive,
everything has to be for everyone.
And my answer is no,
not everything has to be for everyone.
And that's okay.
Not everyone is welcomed my house.
Not everyone's going to enjoy this book.
And you know what?
If you don't think I'm interesting or funny or smart,
I wish you nothing but goodwill.
This a big world,
go live your best life.
Do you think that it doesn't make sense or does it deeply that they're obsessed
with our differences?
They're obsessed with our skin color differences in our sexuality and our gender
difference.
That does.
I mean that is the entire thrust of everything that they're giving us.
And yet they're also the ones that want us to be exactly the same.
Uh,
well is that because,
is that a feature or a bug?
Actually,
I don't know if it's a feature or a bug.
It certainly works for them to some extent because what,
you know,
kind of evangelical ProQuest and isn't,
gives people is a sense of certainty and it also gives them a sense of being
saved.
Right?
So once I recognized the pervasiveness of rec of racism,
I've Kinda been initiated into the mysteries of this faith.
And therefore,
since I'm inherently good,
now I'm in a position to condemn heretics and centers and if necessary,
wiped them off the face of the earth.
So they,
they want us to be the same in terms of being saved,
but they don't want us to be necessarily save in terms of a literal,
yeah.
I don't know that I've ever heard you talk about this specifically,
but how much of what you think is going on with the evangelical left,
as you just described them,
is just a disconnect from faith?
Oh,
I think it's the degeneration of the Social Gospel.
So I traced this so conservatives,
you know when I talk to them,
they're like,
oh,
they admit that the left controls culture and media and Hollywood and thing and
things like that,
and you say,
well,
how did this happen?
And they're like,
we have to have our own version and go,
how did this happen?
They're like,
oh,
it used to be,
I'm like,
when?
When it was the 1930s when literal communists were running Hollywood,
right?
When Woodrow Wilson is playing birth of a nation at the White House,
FDR has so many Democrats that they have to sit on the republican side of the
seats in Congress.
It makes no sense.
Other than that,
you're saying it's not that they lost control,
they never had control.
Correct.
It's always been,
and there's a reason because leftism lends itself to innovation and creativity
because one of the aspects of leftism is liking what's new,
liking what's innovative,
this psychological thing.
And there's nothing wrong with being conservative saying I don't like new stuff.
I like things to say that's if that's fine for you,
but that's going to be a huge disadvantage when you're trying to attract people
who are artistically minded because they're going to be drawn to those who are
maybe not overly openly mine.
Right?
Because it sounds good.
I'm for progress.
Everyone's for price,
but it depends what you're progressing.
Correct.
Right.
Is the rub.
So how conservatives,
how low the left controls culture and built it is one of the big themes of this
book,
and it's I think filling in a big hole on the right because conservatives really
don't know.
And here's another example,
concerns.
You remember our,
sure back in the nineties Jon Stewart,
you know the 2000 excuse me,
was running the show.
And the answer was let's have a conservative daily show.
That's not creativity.
That's just mirroring what someone else has built as opposed to people like I
would say like rush Limbaugh and Roger Ailes,
rush Limbaugh invented basically talk radio made or what it was.
Roger Ailes was told we want you to compete with CNN.
He goes,
no,
no.
I'm going to destroy CNN.
And CNN was all news and he made it this news entertainment opinion thing.
And then CNN followed suit.
So those are two examples of the right actually creating something,
a kind of engineers you think we ever get to.
Something that feels a little more stable.
Again,
I don't work at right now I think stability politically means oppression.
And I think the stability of like,
let's suppose the fifties and this is one thing that I'm hopeful with social
media,
they were entire schools of thought.
They were made invisible because they were threatening to the social order and
now they have to pick people off one by one instead of entire schools of
thought.
And that is progress in a good way.
What if you were picked off?
I'm too charming and I know I,
I mean I can be Glib suck.
It would suck.
I mean what would you do?
I mean,
because I know what a lot of people are thinking.
It's like,
you know,
we've seen enough of the names that we've mentioned throughout this shirt get
picked off and get suspended and get banned.
It's not that there are best buddies or anything,
but there were everyone's sort of in the same sort of circles at some level.
Uh,
again,
coming from that Soviet background,
I know that idea of like it could be you tomorrow.
It's not.
It's always at random cause that way you keep everyone's scared.
It's close to dive into that a little bit more.
Sure.
So one of the techniques that the Soviets did is it wouldn't be like the worst
people who would get kicked off like a barrier said,
find me the man,
I'll find you the crime.
So style and I do not think we're in a style and a society,
I'm just using this as a metaphor,
a very loose metaphor.
I just really want that to be clear because we've got a ways to go before that.
But the,
the principal to keep a population kind of submissive is,
it's not always the loud mouth.
You pick the housewife or you pick this grandma and then everyone knows you
could be next.
So you only got to take out like three people and that 100 are going up
basically fall in line.
And because Twitter's rules are ambiguous and it's seemingly at random and they
don't even give warning,
they could've sat down that AOC account said these three tweets are offensive,
delete them there.
So even though he did nothing wrong by the rules that they supposedly put out
there,
I mean he labeled it as a parody account.
That's the main thing.
And many people have more than one account and very,
and also if you're want to be,
have this kind of public square,
you know,
political conversation.
Once someone is a certain level of stature who are,
you know,
kind of an influencer,
it might be that Jack has to talk to them personally or there has to be three
checks before their band.
Or You could have warnings.
I mean there's a lot of systems for keeping people who are part of this thriving
conversation in place.
But that's not what they want and that's their right.
But this is something that people should recognize.
So you would say that the tech companies want to keep us all in semi-darkness
all the time because that's the easiest way to easy.
But it seems to be effective for them in terms of,
cause then you have self censorship.
Right?
Because you know,
I had this tweet,
I don't even remember what it was and I was scared to put it up because I'm like
at any moment that I have saw Ron can fall on me and on booted.
Yeah.
And I'm sure you know this feeling very well.
So that's what their youtube stuff.
Yeah,
no,
I know it extremely well.
And it's like if I'm even remotely close to where the cliff is,
man,
things have shifted in a seriously dangerous way.
I mean,
there will be a certain amount of people that don't want me talking to you.
There are certain amount of people that didn't want me talking to,
to Cernovich,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And I have to figure out who is who.
I think it's okay to talk about that in the book.
How is it okay for Barbara Walters to sit down with like Kadafi who murdered so
many people?
Uh,
Diane Sawyer with Charles Manson,
I mean with a swastika on his forehead that telling me the Diane Sawyer didn't
endorse all the views of Charles Manson because that seems to be what they say
about if I sit down with somebody,
I must indoors older boy.
It's amazing.
And when they're like,
oh,
he follows this person on Twitter,
it's like everyone follows the president and he's the Dorset.
Like when CNN plays his video,
his speech,
does that mean they're,
they're endorsing it.
So it's a very weird situation again,
because they're legitimate.
You're unorthodox.
You're not legitimate.
You don't have the same rights in a sense that they do.
Well,
we talk about it right before we started,
but you saw the way media,
uh,
media matters went after me cause I was going to have mayor Pete on and
immediately went ahead of him though.
Yeah.
Well,
so that's the thing.
Yeah.
Well,
can you take that away?
I mean you,
you know exactly how it works.
Like they can't,
like when Donald Trump Jr,
uh,
took a tweet of mine and put on Instagram and for days I was spending people
off,
basically it was like,
well,
they can't get a Trump so they're going to get at me.
So if they can meet you,
don't give a crap about media matters,
I'm sure.
But they can sure get to Pete because they'll have his ear and it worked
apparently.
I mean,
think how sad and depressing that is.
Forget,
forget mayor Pete coming in here and doing the show,
it's actually irrelevant.
I would like to have talked to the guy,
but that strikes me is irrelevant.
It's more that either he or his handlers are willing to bow to the mob that he,
you know,
his people basically agree to do an interview.
And then because media matters Huffpo and which the latter two are supposed to
be places of journalism,
they are leveraging,
uh,
or trying to influence a political candidate from calling.
Because the only reason a mayor of Indiana town is in the running for the
presidency is because of Huffpo media matters.
And Vox,
I the idea this a platform for even Senate beggars belief.
So of course he's going to cow tow to the people who put them in the position.
He has this guy's no natural constituencies like 37 years old.
We've got a big battle ahead of us.
Yeah.
And the important thing is,
uh,
to have fun and enjoy life because we're still free and we're still blessed in
this country.
And this is one of the things I do disagree with,
with many POCs than you,
right?
These people think America's ruined were destroyed.
There's no hope.
And it makes me very,
very sad because you go on log in and you find more creative people doing
awesome things,
then you can count.
Yeah.
And we,
we definitely focus,
seemingly we
focus on the negative more,
but that is one of the things that when I see you on Twitter I'm like,
you are actually having fun with it.
Oh yeah.
And there is a need,
this endless political politicy politicization.
Yes.
Did I say that?
You did.
Yeah.
Of everything.
It's making people crazy and depressed.
Uh,
one of the things I really hated about the left and a certain kind of the left
is the idea that the personal is the political.
And to me,
if I disagree with someone politically that this would have any ramification on
our friendship is so profoundly disturbing.
I can't even begin the,
like if,
God forbid,
some of my family dies and I have to look at my phone,
I'd be like,
well,
I can't call this person because they're a Bernie person.
What kind of human order twisted plays twist the place.
And even people who are like regular Christians though,
think in these terms.
Like I have good friends who I'm staying with a couple there.
They're all solid questions.
If my mom,
something happened,
my family,
one of theirs,
I mean,
you're Jewish.
This would never even enter their heads and not even in a million years.
But it's like,
oh,
you're a Trump voter.
You are a Hillary voter.
I can't,
you know,
whatever.
With you,
this is very,
very tribal and disturbing to me.
Have you figured out any ways to deprogram some of these people?
Yes.
A humor.
Um,
I think it's,
I think once you,
I encourage people to see the absurdity of their position and also it's tell
them you can let go.
You don't have to be so ideological all the time.
Life is wonderful.
Enjoy your life and you shouldn't be depressed.
Let's put,
let's suppose Mike Pence,
if you're gay and my prints is president,
that might suck for you.
But come on,
go to what do we,
Whoa,
go to hamburger.
Mary's have fun.
I mean,
this is not really a reflection of your life because they will always be a
president that you hate.
So focus as much as you can.
And this isn't the fairly shocking message on living your life to the fullest.
That's it,
man.
Yeah.
I don't need to ask you anything else.
That's it.
I think let's get people,
regardless of where the politics fall on any of this,
it's like,
let's get people to realize it's still pretty good.
And,
and don't get too caught up in all the literacy.
And just when I'm trolling someone,
just retweet it and sit back and laugh.
Those were all my trials.
Where do you get this jacket?
Uh,
I may,
I know Beluga made it
follow the Willy Wonka of politics.
Michael Malice on the Twitter at Michael Malice.
[inaudible].